yeah he'll hit me burn God my stubby
feet will cut okay well mine lose
muscular so is a muscular indeed flaw
with my four muscular legs I shall
conquer defeat rhyme a centaur creature
from planet zorg on Blair
my legs may be muscular but my arms are
flabby in week 9 messy we're made for
something and that's just what they'll
do oh you four of the four poles it
makes sense
you have nothing Q yog I didn't I need
the other I just got this big boy baby
got back baby got way back good thing I
have these thigh pad
no one's else out my thighs I had nice
big oh yeah yeah whole world will enjoy
my buttocks Hey oonski oonski oonski
okay I veto all this is the worst well
area me fear just there very skinny what
are you talking about ah elbows ha ha we
shall conquer or Dorgan Oh God under 30
but oh my god yeah alright
Oh No yes yes yes yes yes yeah yes oh
god yes oh god oh god yes yes oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah are they ever going back
to this yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah no no
oh oh yeah I like that like some kind of
later [ __ ] candy cane that's nice my
lobon shop historian got a tow and mis
pantalones and Ellen pray do
let's go in play do and I know no way do
la ba la mancha good good play do okay
oh why is the chittering question Oh
where'd my mouse go did we are you
playing oh yeah you're playing now no
you missed it Jesus you were looking
yeah you all fly which means I can't
which spastically in the air hey Wayne
oh I have to find an enemy about we're
gonna change this real quick but all
right you know what we're gonna do since
this is like they're gonna be the last
episode what we're gonna do is we're
gonna each take turns making our ideal
enemy or are the ideal monster and I
think this one deserves to be put away
forever ha ha ha
it was uh it had a short life but uh it
was a good one was a good one
probably going back today hey
oh yeah all right I'm gonna extinct our
species now because it's horrifying hey
never move go yeah yeah grab on the
manger there you go
wake me when it's hilarious okay fine
oh yeah why is it wet I know why is it
wet I don't know why is it what
otherwise wet well there you go ha ha ha
stand out so much for me so obvious they
do not belong oh he's got a wicked strut
on him oh yeah oh I fight with my groin
oh yeah oh well well crotch biting his
head over and over again well that was
lovely I think I'm gonna throw up now ok
no I just not feel like I just know
what's happening Stoney what are you
talking about I just have an idea of
where this might be going I have no idea
what you're talking about I'm flying but
very creativity-wise just I've got I've
got nothing but create through me
oh right now at this point at this
juncture in time Oh God yeah yeah yeah
that's the stuff eyes looking good is
looking good now that I know if it's a
he or she I mean all right I don't want
to go there like I really don't know on
the sport creature creature oh yeah
exactly it's a small creature created
made in the spore creature crater only
in the objects I've never seen something
like that before
what are you talking about hmm I don't
know I just I don't know why I made that
noise but I mean I just kind of feel
hmm you know
yeah oh yeah of course
ah it has to help needs it pointed their
enemies you know planning so that when
they're looking down on it they're like
no no not the Hoggett launchers Oh No
yeah yeah exactly
yes that's my thought process oh you
know love this things yeah suction cups
for the back oh he liked that he liked
that enjoy I like that you're on the
brain area cuz he's a smarty oh that's
looking oh yeah oh yeah some separation
between the neck in the head yeah yes
what are you dad oh no no that's wha
yeah yeah let's see what this bad boy
looks all painted up yeah I've always
thought that this skin was the best skin
that could possibly why are there the
little eye or the wait I
lives again Witten lives again mmm oh
god he's so happy
oh he's bigger than he was before yeah
bit bigger a little bit mo yes a little
more well equipped in that leaf and oh
okay Oh mother yes I'll do that you want
you what like this the way she looks
down on this is the orbit don't nod your
head at me like I got a big oh my
fronting can fly now Oh where's the
sunset that I go hello hi and I need a
whole posse of these guys yeah hey buddy
I bought it bought it buddy get over
over [ __ ] you know what's up I don't
know what you're doing there but I'll do
it but hey how you doing Oh God all
right let's roll out come on we're gonna
take this world by storm baby yeah
yeah baby
oh yeah oh you're a sucker Maya and lies
I don't think I think yeah we could
probably take that grasshopper on come
on
no one can stop me now I think I forgot
to get good weaponry
yeah I'll shoot my nipples at it I mean
rocket launchers indeed oh my god let's
go to this drone already kill 100k
riding off into the sunset now yeah we
can't forget weapons your armor or fly
fly gotta get a good view that a big
screw so much more fine like a majestic
but I love the jiggle the jiggle is my
favorite so thank you everybody so much
for watching our series of Spore
we had a fun time after Tyler stop
playing oh god we were talking like how
hard we were laughing you like Wade
laughs already hurt himself
it's why we had to have the tea yeah
yeah oh this son of a son right up into
the sunset han I got it fly oh good
angle this correctly here it's not quite
setting appropriately but that looks it
well well oh well eventually if I just
keep going to this oh yeah that's it my
god that's beautiful
oh and horrified looks like his arms
like oh my god
I think there's gonna be the end of
Spore for a while
I think they should make a sport to I
mean just maybe let's ride back into the
ocean where this belongs alright so
thank you everybody so much for watching
I don't think we're gonna be playing
spore again okay well oh you were right
I was right oh so thanks again everyone
and as always we will see you in the
next video bye bye
ice oh no we have to watch the birth
again Oh God hi mama
I'm ready for puberty to hell any minute
now yeah it's really grow hi mother
Oh the lighting is like really creepy
right now yeah it is Oh Oh mother
oh hey hello mmm I like the way you
jiggle yes thrust it upon me
all right to see if the mating looks
like oh why not
this one's ready to go Herbert Herbert
yeah yeah
and then the celebration dance
Oh God
don't kill me okay they wanna kill me
right here
oh you were right I was right you